when historians look back at this time
500 years from now
they will put a breaking point
right where we build a space elevator
this is
free space and this was post
this is
an entire new society
everything changes
[Music]
imagine simply climbing a cable into
space
no rocket
just press the up button
and you're there
[Music]
the concept is known as the space
elevator
not only could it significantly change
how we leave planet earth
but it could also completely transform
humanity's relationship with space
and there are scientists who think we
could have already built it
we have the material we have the
technology we have the lasers we have
the climbers we have all of them
if a private entity wants to build it
or a government they can build it
it'll change society we have no clue how
colonizing in the space how really
spreading out of space will really
change our society over the next 50 to
200 years
it'll be completely different
[Music]
[Music]
ideas of a space elevator type device
extend as far back as the 19th century
russian and american scientists came up
with various theories for a structure
built from earth's surface that would
reach the stars
by 1979 the concept was relayed to a
larger audience by writer arthur c
clarke in his novel the fountains of
paradise
i'm happy that people are taking it
you know more and more seriously and i
do think that it may be the way to space
but these ideas struggle to advance
beyond the realms of science fiction
as we continue to rely on tried and
tested methods of getting into space
right now we've got rockets
they use a lot of fuel they take a lot
of fuel to get up into space they have
to carry fuel to lift the fuel
to lift them into space
if you want to go to geosynchronous
orbit it's millions of dollars per pound
if you want to go to the moon or mars
it's expensive with the space elevator
we reduce the cost of getting into space
to
dollars per pound each climber will
ascend the ribbon
every day every couple days and it'll be
taking 15 25 100 tons into orbit which
is comparable to what we launched now
over the course of a year
[Music]
so how does the space elevator even work
the basic idea is a cable would be
pulled taut thanks to a counterweight
it stays vertical because the
counterweight is thrown outward by the
earth's rotation and the base is held
down by gravity
take a look at this ball on the end of
this string
if you swing the ball in a circle at a
sufficient speed the rope will become
taut revolving around your hand
the force pulling the rope taut is
centrifugal acceleration
this force generated by the rotation of
the earth in space will pull the space
elevator tether upwards into space and
away from the earth
in reality the ball would have to be a
large counterweight and positioned above
geosynchronous orbit
that's 22
236 miles above the earth's surface
this is where the outward force pulling
it away from earth is greater than the
downward pull of gravity and that keeps
the elevator line taut
early ideas suggested building a cable
from earth up into space but the
materials needed to withstand such
enormous weight don't exist
physicist bradley edwards breathed new
life into the theory
i've been working on the space elevator
along with a number of other
space systems and new technologies for
the better part of 30 some years
i searched for years to find a reason
why we couldn't build a space elevator
the materials the climbers the power
beaming the low earth orbit you know
debris
radiation
just any number of things why couldn't
we build it
there was no reason and that was where
it started and i wrote a paper up in
1998 with everything i had found
how you would design it how you would
build it any problems issues that i
found
and i published it thinking well okay
someone's going to publish the next
paper saying okay great brad but
you know what you forgot this this this
and this and so we can't build it
it it never happened
brad edwards proposal was written for
nyack nasa's institute for advanced
concepts
niacc wanted to look at those things
that might really change the future so
we put out a broad call for innovative
ideas
we got an interesting batch of proposals
right off the bat
and one of those came from a researcher
brad edwards one of nasa's initial
responses when we brought it to the
table as a funded study before we ever
brought it up you know they sort of
dismissively said we we hope you're not
bringing anything like a space elevator
in as part of your funded studies
to nasa's credit they said okay we
understand now why you're going to
pursue this and you know proceed
the
problem with earlier versions of the
space elevator was we just didn't have a
way to um to build the cable that was
needed to maintain a space elevator and
brad came up with an innovative twist
looking into the future on where carbon
nanotubes might go in terms of strength
carbon nanotubes are something of a
super material
despite their tiny size they're
theoretically stronger than things like
kevlar or graphene
brad edwards suggested launching a
rocket which would carry the carbon
nanotube cable
one end of the cable would then be
dropped back towards earth
the cable would be light enough and
strong enough to build just a thin
ribbon which robots could climb to build
more ribbon
eventually becoming strong enough to
carry heavy payloads such as solar
panels satellites and even tourists
so you have to launch all this mass to
begin with
and then start building
the elevator
hence the earlier version that had
incredibly massive
cables just were impractical
but now
if the projection of the links were to
work out
then maybe you'd have something you know
that could become feasible you know a
few years ago the only carbon nanofibers
were microscopic you know a couple of
years later they were millimeters now
we're talking about things that are
centimeters and if you project that
growth because people are putting more
and more in
interest in carbon nanofibers then in 20
years we might have carbon nanofibers
that are kilometers long
while there have been huge steps in
advancing the technology some people
still have their doubts
carbon nanotubes exist they're available
but
there hasn't been money going into
commercializing them
we've made them we have
put them into plastics and they increase
it dramatically
the strongest steel has a strength of
about five gigapascals
carbon fibers
kevlar
these conventional materials
they will have strengths of about the
same
anywhere between two and seven
gigapascals carbon nanotubes
these are measured
at 150 to 200 gigapascals
what we need to build a space elevator
is about 60.
so
carbon nanotubes in these bags are three
times as strong as we need to make the
space elevator
and we can grow them long so what about
the cost of carbon nanotubes is this the
biggest hurdle literally in our system
it costs us about a dollar a gram right
now on a small scale
we turn that into production
the
costs are going to go down
now at a dollar a gram that's pretty
expensive
and we need about a thousand tons to
build the first space elevator that's
going to be a billion dollars
a billion dollars is a lot of money
but when you talk about
building the space elevator for a total
of eight billion dollars a large chunk
of it being those carbon nanotubes what
you can launch with that system
we easily spend that money launching
satellites and whatever else we might
launch over the next 10 20 years it's
not that expensive
to put that 8 billion figure in context
nasa just spent 10 billion on the
recently launched james webb telescope
and if brad edwards cost estimate is
accurate the world's space-faring nation
spent enough to cover 10 space elevators
in 2020 alone
nasa chose not to pursue the space
elevator concept despite things like
carbon nanotubes getting longer and
stronger so why do you think that was a
space elevator doesn't exist in
isolation it exists along with
everything else that's in orbit in earth
and while brad came up with a very
clever
design to allow his space elevator
tether to survive
a few hits every now and then and he
came up with some approaches to allow
the space elevator to do an elaborate
dance to avoid
larger satellites that might be coming
through its path
the space debris issue today is a real
real challenge for a space elevator
concept
[Music]
there's an estimated 128 million objects
smaller than a centimeter orbiting the
earth
along with another 900 000 that measure
1 to 10 centimeters
all with the potential to cause
significant damage
brad edwards's concept would see a space
elevator mounted to a mobile oil
rig-like structure to dodge any
dangerous material
it's really hard to imagine that you
could have a space elevator that could
survive the number of collisions that
one would expect
over the lifetime of a space elevator
and you know if the ribbon's cut you're
having a bad day brad what do you think
about the risks of something hitting the
elevator you know tracking orbital
debris there's commercial ventures out
there that do that so you know to a
large extent we don't even have to deal
with it there's also risks on earth you
know
a plane or you know a ship or even a
storm could impact the structure if the
elevator does break
that'll be pretty devastating
you'll see the elevator in various
science fiction movies things like that
and invariably the space elevator comes
down and does this crashing terrible
wrap around the planet destroying
everything in its way again we're
talking about ribbon three feet wide
thinnest paper
if you break it if you if you break the
top part off
the the counterweight what happens is
the ribbon starts to come down and then
it breaks
because the tension increases it breaks
at the bottom and the entire
ribbon flies out into space never to be
seen again
so what you get are a few pieces of this
black material lightweight
material that falls down but it's not
going to destroy a building it's not
going to break your neck if you cut it
to the bottom the entire space elevator
flies off into space never to be seen
again
another reason the elevator hasn't
materialized is the dramatic falling
price of launching into space thanks to
the likes of spacex and their reusable
rockets but as more countries and
companies are sending payloads into
space a real space economy is growing
it's estimated the global space industry
could surge to over one trillion dollars
by 2040.
a space elevator could bring huge
returns for the team that builds it
which is maybe why a japanese
construction company is funding some
research
a team from nihon university in tokyo
are building robot climbers that ascend
synthetic cable focusing on increasing
speed and minimizing power consumption
[Music]
[Music]
me
the company backing the research
obayashi corporation believes a space
elevator could aid missions to the moon
and mars the scientists say the biggest
hurdles are beyond their control
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the space shower has to be operated
in a way that it benefits everyone
it has to be that
you know most anybody can launch on it
nobody launches any weapons any military
anything on it
it sort of has to go that way otherwise
it gets destroyed
so it comes out where
it's almost forced to be a positive
thing
otherwise it goes away
[Music]
there's plenty holding back a space
elevator here on earth
something building one on the moon might
be the best way to prove the technology
thanks to the moon's lack of atmosphere
it would also mean the cable could be
made from weaker existing materials and
it'd be much cheaper
but while still useful it wouldn't give
us the huge savings of sending payloads
into space from earth
either way the space elevator is still a
long long way off
i would love to be proven wrong
if we had a space elevator it would be
awesome it would be paradigm changing
because you know if we can get to the
point of a space elevator yes it
provides
incredible access uh to space so i'd
love to be proven wrong
where the space elevator might take the
human species is one thing
what we bring back to earth
might be more important than we think we
can colonize the moon the mars we can go
to the asteroids cheaply and we can mine
them for
minerals metals that we're running out
of now here on earth
and instead of digging up tearing up a
pristine rainforest someplace to get to
those metals underneath
we can go to a barren rock that is
nothing more than
a large piece of those metals collect
them up
bring them back to earth without the
destruction
it's changed from
back in 1998
it was science fiction you know
capturing asteroids bringing them in
building large cables
and now we've we have it and
we probably could have started building
it 10 years ago
[Music]
[Applause]
you